how can we help you
Boomer hey Sam I am calling uh I don't
know if you do General Christian advice
I don't know it depends it depends on
what advice it is but before you do what
is your background you're a Christian
then yeah I grew up Southern Baptist uh
from Texas all my from Texas but I've
been recently trying to get into the
Orthodox Church I'm visiting we we have
a local community here okay um and
unfortunately my uh spiritual leader
has uh been unable to answer my question
what is it let me see I I don't know let
me see it's it's not a technical it's
it's a very simple question which is I
have been unable to
feel the the the presence of
any anything right yeah I have no
logical reason yeah to you're talking
about you feel nothing yes that's my
problem well that's brother brother
that's too easy if you base it on
feeling you will not be successful in
anything you do in life what do I mean
if you base it on feeling your marriage
will fail your friendships will sh fail
you'll fail at every Endeavor because
you have to go beyond your feelings and
do it as an act of discipline because
the Christian Life is described as
discipline discipline if you go to and I
my connection might give out I don't
know what's going on for Now 1
Corinthians
9427 I'm going to share it to the Bible
says that the Christian Life is
discipline what you're used to is you
got to feel it no you don't have to feel
it do you think when Christians were
being in prison or even today in prison
and beaten and whipped and tortured and
then beheaded or killed they feel
good
no so if we go with feeling you're not
going to last not only in any religion
not just Christianity you're not going
to last
in anything not even a marriage do you
know that one of the reasons why
marriages feel is because a husband
checks out emotionally or a wife checks
out emotionally and they say well I
don't feel and they think that's just
and
then because they go
by yeah and I know thankfully my parents
are still together but my friends went
through that one of my best friends went
through that with his parents so so I
not about feelings correct all right so
what is it it's
discipline let me show discipline yeah
let me show it to you the Bible itself
and the Bible warns about going with
your feelings going with how you feel
and I'm letting you know if you're not
married yet you're not married yet no
I'm letting you know buddy my feelings
you not last in any
relationship okay here let me show you
nothing but feelings now it's a because
it seems like I'm losing connection guys
I may you're breaking up on my end as
well yeah I'm losing connection all
right now the connection seems to be
getting better okay so what was I saying
remember talking about feelings and you
said the Bible addresses discipline all
right and I said you can't go by
feelings because you're going to then
check out of every relationship so why
you waiting
for what you feel when you're supposed
to take God at a word trust what he says
not go by how you feel so this is what a
relationship is and what trusting God
looks like trusting God means you take
him out his word no matter how you feel
so you
ready ready all right because it sounds
like you're coming in and out do you not
know 1 Corinthians 9:2 24:27 that all
those who run in a race run but one
receives the price so did you see how
the Christian Life is being described as
a
competition yes you run a race well to
run a race and to win implies a lot of
discipline physically eating right
exercising a whole ton to then be fit
enough to run the race and finish it
right yeah that's
um that's the difficult part well that's
why you got to stop being lazy that's
true that's the problem you it's you're
lazy and you want everything handed to
you and you want to be spoonfed says no
I'm sorry it doesn't work like that you
have to exert you have to put in energy
you have to strive so run that you may
obtain it everyone who strives for the
prize exercises self-control in all
things see
it now they do it to obtain a
corruptible Crown so when they compete
for UFC belt that we is going to
fade right but we an Incorruptible one
we run a spiritual race we engage in
spiritual training for a spiritual
battle spiritual competition and our
reward is an Imperial Crown so therefore
I run not with
uncertainty so I fight not as one who
beats the air say fight boxing but I
bring in keep my but into subjection
lest when preaching to others I myself
should be disqualified right now watch
First 1timothy 48 you listening yes for
bodily exercise profits a little but
godliness is profit among all things
holding promise for the present life and
also for the life to come so did you
understand how he described
Christianity he described living The
Godly life as exercise training and
discipline
that's uh very applicable to me I uh I
go to the gym a lot exactly but I don't
think I open my bible enough because
laziness but if you don't go to the gym
like me I haven't gone for a week and
you sit home and eat what happens to you
you start losing muscle and then you get
fat
right uh yes and you become lethargic
and you become weak and you become lazy
right yes but it's hard to go to the
gymm because you're tired and you might
you might have come from work or school
and you want to go sleep or you got to
get up 5 in the morning and you don't
want to do it but you force yourself and
when you're done you feel better that
you did it and then the results are
phenomenal now you're full of energy and
you have the physical stamina to do
things that you could not do if you're
not healthy but that required sacrifice
and discipline and going against how you
feel right it was definitely harder at
first to go to the gym now later it
became easier yeah now it's a habit well
that's what Paul says you got to do to
yourself you got to force yourself
discipline yourself to pray even when
you don't like to read your Bible
meditate on when you don't like to get
to church and then the more you do it
then it becomes second nature in time so
you got to go against how you feel and
do not base it on how you feel base it
on God's promise prising if you do this
this is what will happen and here
Proverbs 28:26 he who trusts in his own
heart is a fool whatever walks wisely
will be delivered so you're going by
feeling God says you're a
fool yeah that's uh unfortunately
nothing against the pastor that I grew
up with but he taught a lot of feeling
in his sermons I grew up always like um
everybody around me would tell me like
oh I can't believe like you don't feel
anything with the Holy Spirit wow how
are you feeling anything that's that
that was the situation I grew up in tell
me tell me if this feels good Look what
Jesus said Matthew 16 24 to 27 so hope
that answered your question go stop
going by how you feel man do what is
right I don't feel like going doing
cardio tonight I feel like sitting here
and stuffing my face so feel good no
cardio is the
worst thank you but I feel like sitting
eating more pizza and ice cream and that
feels good but then I feel fat and
sluggish and I feel miserable because
I'm getting fat but if I go and do that
hour cardio I feel alive and alert and I
feel good now watch Matthew 16427 then
Jesus said to his disciples if anyone
will come after me let him deny himself
and take up his cross and follow me now
being crucified does that feel good uh
no not at all so Jesus told you if you
want to know how you're gonna feel
you're gonna feel pain you're GNA feel
discomfort you're gonna feel tribulation
you're going to feel sadness because
following me comes at a price being
hated being insulted being persecuted
losing friendships and also it requires
you dying to what pleases you which is
painful that's why he says it's taking
up your
cross and he knows it's hard he said it
that's why he says whoever would save
his life will lose it whoever loses his
soul life for my sake will find it for
what will it profit a man if he gains a
whole world and loses his own soul
or what shall a man give in exchange for
his soul for the son of man shall come
with his angels and the Glorious father
and they'll repay every man according to
his works so there you go black and
white brother yeah so stop you feel
brother go by
discipline yeah that you broke it down
in a way that I could understand thank
you final one for you Hebrews 121 And by
the way read the the chapter before
Hebrews 11 it gives you the Hall of
faithful the faithful one of God and the
hell they went through let me show you
and then he sayses are your examples and
these are the ones who are now
witnessing you running the same race on
Earth they did and they finished here
watch here Hebrews 11:37 38 watch what
happened to them okay they were stoned
some of them were stoned does that feel
good no so could you say hey buddy hold
on man I didn't sign up for this it
doesn't feel good dude so you know this
Christianity is not for me yeah that's
uh one of the reasons I was attracted to
the Orthodox Church was their induction
process yeah where they didn't
immediately accept everybody into the
church you had to prove amen amen now
watch this they were sa in two people
were cut in half you think it feels good
being saw in half not any more than
stoned okay they were tempted were slain
with the sword they wander around in
sheep skins goat skins meaning they were
pretty much living as homeless as
Vagabond because they had to flee to the
mountains and the Wilderness and eat
Locust and honey and try to find water
because people are after them trying to
kill them and that scorching heat or
freezing cold that didn't make them feel
good while destitute Afflicted and
tormented but now look what it says
about them they endured in spite of how
they felt they endured in spite of how
they felt and it says the world was not
worthy of them they wandered in deserts
and mountains and dens and caves of the
earth now you know why this is a
beautiful
testimony no I don't it means they were
too good for this world that's why they
belong to
Heaven ah I see the world was not worthy
to have such holy righteous people they
were too good for this
world and that's why they belong to
Heaven may it be said of you and I that
the world did not deserve to have you
and I walking on
it but you won't have that testimony if
you go by how you feel because if you go
by you feel you're going to check out
from the faith you're going to check out
from your relationship you're going to
check out from your marriage because you
ain't feeling it and then here's
exhortation to us Hebrews
okay
therefore after giving you all these
people and what they went through since
we are encompassed surrounded with such
a great cloud of witnesses now notice
again he describes it as a competition
as exercise as Athletics they used to
have the Olympics the Greeks right and
they would run
races such a great clot of witnesses so
the imagery is like of a Coliseum
Amphitheater and people are watching you
run the race and who are those people
those who finish the race and are in
heaven and now watching and praying for
you to make it let us also lay aside
every weight and sin put away your sin
that so easily entangles us makes it
harder for us for run to run the race
and finish it and let us run with
endurance the race that is set before us
but now the Supreme example right after
saying that look at the example and then
I'll leave you that watch
here watch here who's the Supreme
example of that the Supreme example if
you're listening guys and don't engage
each other in the comment section that
means you're not
learning who's the Supreme example let
us look to Jesus your Supreme example
the author and finisher of our way Faith
he started their faith and he completed
it he brought about salvation he
accomplished salvation and he became an
example for us how to obtain that
salvation who for the joy that was set
before him endured the cross despising
the shame did you see it yes Jesus on
Earth did not have it easy Jesus on
Earth had to endure the cross he
practiced what he pre preached he
carried his own cross he was humiliated
he was despised he was
insulted and he was beaten whipped
nailed and killed that doesn't feel good
he had it worse than anyone but look why
he did it because he wasn't looking at
the present temporary
fleeting circumstances meaning he wasn't
looking simply to what was happening to
him on Earth he looked ahead the result
of his work on Earth and what was the
result of that work that by enduring
that pain and humilation he would
accomplish the salvation of all who
turned to him and for that he was joyful
so he didn't focus on the present pain
he looked ahead to what this would
result is the fruit of his suffering
multitudes being saved and that
became the fuel
for him to endure it and now he sits at
the right hand of the Throne of God for
consider him Jesus who endured such
hostility from Sinners against himself
lest you become weary and your hearts
give up he's your
example you got
it yes I'm just sorry I'm just realizing
how dead I was exactly you know seems
like you're crying too brother sorry we
all cry Jesus makes your own men
cry I don't know if it's your mic or you
sound like you're crying you crying
brother no I'm not there yet I might be
because you remember you're emotionless
you're dead you have no feelings yeah
just your mic but you understand now
right I do that that
um what's you like uh I feel like I've
woken up a little bit you need to wake
up you got to stop going by how you feel
because it's not about nothing but
feelings h the song
says the heart don't lie or nothing but
feelings that's all a
lie the heart will deceive you your
emotions will deceive you in fact ask
anyone and everyone who is impulsive and
let their emotions get the best of them
and they went ahead did something
because of their feelings like I just
did earlier when I let my anger get the
best of me you regret
it you realize the mistake you made the
damage you did and you regret doing it
but it's too late
yes ask people hey buddy that thing you
did at that moment because you felt good
doing it whether adultery or you lashed
out in anger how's that going for you
now I regret the day I did it no you
always regret it you always regret it
see now watch here Jeremiah
179 the heart is more deceitful than all
things and desperately wicked who can
understand it so why would you trust
your heart your
emotions true so that's it my friend
there you
go thank you so much to the church and
just forget about your feelings learn
discipline it's like working out
discipline discipline thank you all
right buddy stop being a boomer or you
like be a
boomer all right thank you have a good
night take care